the movie begins in ancient rome an
architect named lucius is failing to
come up with new innovations and is
struggling with money every idea he
comes up with is rejected by the clients
who think his innovations are outdated
one afternoon lucius's friend brings him
to a public bathhouse to unwind lucius
thinks it is the worst place to relax
since it is filled with loud naked
people overwhelmed by the environment he
goes underwater and stays there for a
while suddenly he notices a small
whirlpool forming on the other side of
the tub he goes to check it out but is
pulled by a strong current in only a few
seconds lucius ends up in a tunnel-like
place struggling to breathe he tries his
best to get to the surface and is
finally successful but to his surprise
he is not in a roman bathhouse anymore
in fact he is in a modern japanese
bathhouse filled with old men who are in
shock to see him stand naked in front of
them the architect has somehow traveled
through time to modern day japan lucius
who has never seen someone with
mongolian features assumes that the men
are from a flat-faced tribe after
recovering from the shock lucius notices
that the place is more advanced than any
bathhouse he has ever seen the baskets
taps and massaging device all blow his
mind as he regrets not thinking of these
innovations himself earlier he also
accidentally enters the women's changing
room and is knocked out by a screaming
old lady then we are introduced to a
struggling manga artist named mami his
appearance gives her an idea for a new
character hence she starts drawing his
portrait a while later lucius wakes up
and is given a bottle of flavored milk
he is yet again baffled by the sweet and
cold taste of it in fact it is so good
that it makes him fall unconscious for a
second time when he regains
consciousness he is back in rome
surrounded by men they say that he
drowned in the tub and was found a few
minutes ago initially lucius thinks his
encounter with the flat-faced tribe was
only a dream a racist dream but then he
notices the empty milk bottle at his
side the scene cuts to two months later
lucius proposed his renovation idea to
the owner of the bath house and made it
more advanced people praise his
creativity and he makes a lot of money
off of it they now use baskets massage
booths and even sweet milk to enhance
their bath house experience while in the
tub an old man wishes that he had a bath
house at home as lucius is thinking of a
way to make that possible he is again
pulled by a current and brought to a
bathtub in the 21st century a man comes
inside and asks lucius to help him bathe
lucius is confused but he does is told
and finds out about many more useful
tools like the shower head and the
shower hat coincidentally the house
belongs to mammy who finds lucius on the
floor she runs to get her sketchbook but
when she returns he has already
disappeared back in rome lucius makes a
house bathtub for the old man and earns
a lot of money he finally has enough to
feed his wife good meals but she is not
satisfied she desperately wants to have
a baby and complains that lucius is
always busy working they get into an
argument that ends when she curses him
and storms away a few days later lucius
is approached by a messenger of the
emperor hadianus the man is known for
being cruel as rumors say that he killed
the cabinet members who opposed him
since the talk about lucius's inventions
has been going around town even the
emperor is taking interest in him upon
meeting lucius he reveals that he is an
admirer of art and what lucius has done
with the public bathhouse is clearly a
form of it impressed by his work the
emperor wants him to make a personal
bath for himself he demands that it must
be out of the ordinary innovative and
something that has never been done
before lucius accepts the challenge and
makes it his mission to impress the
emperor the entire night he goes around
the town looking for inspiration for a
grand bathhouse but finds nothing he is
embarrassed that all his ideas are a
copy that he shouldn't get credit for
suddenly he falls into a ditch and
disappears a scene from current times
shows us mammy working at a bathroom
supply store her career as a manga
artist is not going well so she has
taken a side job but even then she is
struggling to stay awake at work one
afternoon she accidentally leaves the
water on and fills a tub to its brim
suddenly lucius appears in the tub and
starts breathing frantically he stops
when he realizes the tub is bubbling on
its own the manager of the shop goes to
complain about the strange man giving
mammy and lucius time to socialize
lucius asks her to give him a tour of
the place and hands her a coin although
mammy doesn't understand his spoken
language she does understand the
language of cold hard cash and she shows
him around lucius is mesmerized by the
urinals and thinks printed toilet paper
contains the secrets of the flat-faced
tribe's success i really wish i didn't
have to keep narrating that term but the
thing that fascinates him the most is a
bidet when he is on it he feels like he
is in heaven copying the idea from
everything he saw he returns to rome and
makes the emperor the best bathhouse of
all time it has a toilet with constant
water flow to clean the behind a tub
with bubbles made from slaves blowing up
a pipe a glowing aquarium and scented
candles he exceeds the emperor's
expectations and is awarded a special
necklace that has a unique sculpture of
dog legs and human genitals lucius runs
home to show the achievement to his wife
but finds her making love to his best
friend damn in the future mamie returns
to her small hometown after repeatedly
failing to generate ideas for a good
manga and being kicked out of her side
jobs she starts working in a local
bathhouse and studying ancient roman
history the coin she received from
lucius and his disappearance has
intrigued her and she wants to know if
he is actually a person from the past
back in rome lucius has lost the will to
live after his wife ran away with his
best friend one day he is approached by
a messenger who is worried about the
emperor it turns out that the emperor
lost his son recently and thinks that a
crocodile is his reincarnation he wants
lucius to design a place where the
crocodile can be stored and all of his
needs are met lucius has to be extra
careful with this one because if the
animal dies all blame will fall upon him
and he will be declared a national
criminal following that lucius goes back
to the emperor's bathhouse to check the
water flow at his request but when he
enters the tub he is pulled into the
future for the third time he comes
outside and finds himself in a cage
stuck with crocodiles it turns out he is
in a crocodile sanctuary at the same
time mammy is also at the sanctuary with
a date who she doesn't like she tries
her best to get rid of the guy and is
happy upon seeing lucius inside the cage
she brings him out and shows him around
the sanctuary forgetting all about her
date lucius learns how to take proper
care of crocodiles and their preferred
habitat mimi also takes him to learn
archery to see if he is really a roman
man he hits all the targets confirming
her suspicion a while later he ends up
in a hot spring which takes him back to
his time a few months later the emperor
gets a perfect place to breed his
crocodile son he has even started to
treat lucius like family inviting him to
the palace frequently everything is
going well in the city until one day the
emperor is informed of the rebels making
an attack on his troops they are not
happy with his rule and want to dethrone
him at any cost the emperor's soldiers
and the rebels fight a long and hard
battle that goes on for more than a year
by now the emperor has grown old and is
ready to retire he plans to leave the
throne to his nephew cionius for
sionias's first project as the emperor
he is going to build a new bathhouse to
gain the people's support hence the
emperor wants lucius to help his nephew
in the project this is a problem for
lucius because his principles do not
align with sionias who is arrogant and
proud lucius knows that if he becomes
the emperor the fall of the roman empire
is inevitable hence after giving it much
thought he goes to ceonius and refuses
to work for him cionius reminds him that
going against the emperor is treason
punishable by death but lucius remains
adamant he goes to a fellow architect
and begs him to take the project however
the man is furious at lucius for being
the reason he is broke they get into a
fight and lucius is pushed into a wall
in the next scene he is with the
flat-faced tribe again he is hurt but
they are taking care of him as their own
they bring him to a hot spring where he
can rest and recover it is said that if
he bathed in the water of a spring a
person can heal quickly they also give
him fermented alcohol which burns his
throat then lucius meets mammy who has
learned to speak basic latin she asks
him his name but lucius is so drunk that
he falls on top of her and the two drown
in the lake when they wake up they are
in rome much to mammy's amazement she
finds out that lucius is about to be
executed for refusing to oblige the
emperor's order worried she tries to
convince him to take the project but it
doesn't work lucius leaves home with his
luggage to save his life meanwhile in
japan the group of old men are looking
for mammy when they fall into the lake
like lucius they also get stuck in a
whirlpool and are brought to the past
lucius is on his way to a different city
when he comes across a natural hot
spring on a hill he remembers the way he
was treated by the tribe and realizes
that the spring can be useful to the
emperor's wounded soldiers he rushes to
mammy to tell her of his idea which she
agrees with following that lucius goes
to the emperor and presents him with the
vision he also claims that he was
instructed by antonius to make the
spring antonius is another possible heir
to the throne who is much more eligible
than ceonus hence lucius wants to make
him look better in the emperor's eyes
after being permitted to make the spring
lucius mammy and the tribe get to work
in the next few hours they make the
first hut gradually many houses are
built around the spring and they turn
into a resting point for the soldiers
the tribe takes care of the wounded and
helps them recover quickly they also use
their knowledge of modern medicine to do
so a few months later the soldiers win
the battle against the rebels they
celebrate by drinking and dancing lucius
and mammy sit in private and chat for a
long time they have developed feelings
for each other over the time they worked
together lucius is the happiest he has
ever been in life that is until the
tribe suddenly disappears mammy also
starts vanishing in front of his eyes
but before she does he tells her that
there are several ways leading back to
rome in the following scene the emperor
makes antonius his advisor lucius is
also awarded in front of the civilians
for the bravery he showed in battle
people acknowledged that without him
they would have never won meanwhile
mammy has started a new life in the
future one day she is walking through
the city when she sees lucius come out
of a pond the movie ends as they meet
each other again subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching